[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver ici dans la salle des
conférences du sénat pendant la crise
sanitaire du coronavirus toutes les
équipes de public sénat se mobilise pour
vous faire vivre les travaux des
sénateurs qui contrôlent l'action du
gouvernement et ce matin les sénateurs
vont auditionner les membres du conseil
scientifique
le président du conseil scientifique
jean françois delfraissy et puis avril
aux encres spéciales east des nouvelles
technologies alors ce conseiller
scientifique il a été créé au début de
la crise sanitaire par le président de
la république
emmanuel macron les experts qui en sont
membres sont chargés de rendre des avis
sur les divers aspects de cette crise
sanitaire et ce matin les sénateurs vont
les interroger sur les mesures de
traçage numérique qui doivent permettre
d'enrayer l'épidémie notamment pendant
la période de déconfinement on sait que
le gouvernement travaille actuellement
sur une application de traçage numérique
qui dirait à ses utilisateurs
si l'on croisé ou non des personnes
infectées une application sur la base du
volontariat mais qui inquiète certains
sénateurs soucieux de préserver les
libertés individuelles
l'audition du conseil scientifique s'est
tout de suite surviso animations et donc
de faire que le système de soins puisse
tenir le choc
par rapport par rapport à l'afflux du
nombre de personnes entrant réanimation
et deuxièmement et donc ça je dirais clé
des éléments sont plutôt on va on est
plutôt dans le bon sens en ce moment
vous le savez c'est à la fois vrai dans
dans l'est de la france c'est vrai en
région parisienne et les chiffres que
nous avons au monde qu'il ya une
décroissance non pas en termes de
mortalité c'est là où est la complexité
il va puisqu'il ya décalage entre un
moment on rentre en réanimation et un
moment où malheureusement on peut
décéder met donc les chiffres de
mortalité sont là tous les jours où les
âmes où les avaient ils sont ils ne
bougent pas et ils ne vont pas encore
bougé pendant une dizaine quinzaine de
jours et est néanmoins nous nous avons
déjà lente par sur les modèles que nous
avons une anticipation buée et de la vie
en vrai hein c'est pas seulement les
modèles mais d'une d'une baisse très
régulière
du nombre de personnes qui vont entrer
en réanimation dans les semaines qui
viennent pour aboutir finalement quelque
chose de beaucoup plus stabilisée qui
permettra d'ailleurs de s'occuper aussi
des personnes qu'ovide négatif puisque
vous savez quand on est très inquiet
d'une certaine mesure de la comorbidité
qui va y avoir avec avec de ski ce qui
n'est pas que vides et il faut il faut
avoir cette vision de santé global qui
est vraiment très importante
le deuxième objectif heures pourquoi
j'ai démarré là dessus parce que le
deuxième objectif de du confinement
c'est aussi dans une certaine mesure de
ralentir l'épidémie est de faire qu'on
se trouve à la sortie du confinement
avec un niveau de vitesse de
renouvellement de l'épidémie que vous
savez on mesure parce cet indice qu'on
appelle le r0 c'est à dire la capacité
d'une personne infectée à infecter
d'autres d'autres personnes et et qu'on
fasse nettement baissé le r0 justement
pour qu'on puisse se trouver à partir de
la mi mai dans des conditions qui
permettraient d'avoir une stratégie de
type à la coréenne
c'est à dire avec tous les outils dont
on va parler après alors que savons-nous
sur est ce que nous avons pu faire
baisser ou pas avec avec le confinement
cette vitesse de l'épidémie et l'airé
pensons plutôt oui c'est à dire qu'on
est parti d'un air 0 début mars qui
était à 3 4 3 3 5 qui était
essentiellement lié je vous rappelle que
la france aurait pu se trouver à peu
près dans la situation de l'allemagne
mais qu'on a eu malheureusement
l'épisode de mulhouse qui a qui a
complètement fait dissimuler le virus
ainsi sinon on serait probablement dans
les conditions de l'allemagne
actuellement et qui a et qui a fait
exploser entre guillemets on a eu les
deux clusters la fois de mulhouse et de
l'oise mesloise avait été en partie
contrôlée mais c'est surtout mulhouse et
on est parti donc avec une dissémination
très général un taux de 0 0 très élevé
variable selon les régions pour des
raisons d'ailleurs qu'on ne comprend pas
bien
toujours pas compris pourquoi le
sud-ouest en dehors du foie gras et du
bordeaux était et est à ce niveau là
2h01 relativement faible et donc ce le
confinement a fait baisser entre
guillemets ce 1-0 alors qu'est-ce qu'on
anticipe j'ai évidemment pas les
chiffres
je prédis ont prédit pas l'avenir mais
nos modèles et les modélisations jusqu'à
maintenant se sont pas beaucoup trompé
malheureusement moi je pensais qu'elles
seront plus et que la réalité serait
plus favorable mais se sont pas beaucoup
trompé montre qu' on pourrait obtenir 1
heure 0 2 lors de 2,07 à peu près c'est
à dire avec une baisse drastique du
nombre de nouvelles contaminations
donc ensuite qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que parce que c'est la
question que plutôt qu'on nous pose
ok tout ça c'est bien gentil mais
finalement quand vous quand va se
rouvrir doucement une sortie de
confinement il va ya voir combien de
nouvelles on peut s'y met à peu près à
combien de nouvelles contaminations vont
survenir vont survenir chaque jour en
france puisque en fonction du nombre de
nouvelles contaminations
vous comprenez bien que les outils qu'on
va mettre en face pour essayer de tracer
ces nouvelles contaminations pour
essayer de à la fois 2-2 les traces et
d'isoler que c'était on y reviendra
et bien évidemment c'est le quantitatif
a quand même une certaine une certaine
idée nous n'avons pas les chiffres
nous n'avons pas les chiffres et c'est
extrêmement difficile de les avoir alors
on a des chiffres théoriques je vais
vous en parler un tout petit peu et puis
comment peut-on calculer le nombre de
contaminations
il faut les mesurer et vous savez que
jusqu'à maintenant nous n'avions pas
suffisamment de tests pour les mesures
et c'est la très grosse différence par
rapport à d'autres pays
deuxièmement on peut les les théoriser
les calculer avec les modèles puis
troisièmement on peut les calculé à
partir des personnes qui rentrent en
réanimation
c'est à dire ça c'est du solide c'est on
compte les personnes qui rentrent en
réanimation et voyez bien que pour
rentrer en réanimation il faut avoir été
infectés et donc qu'il ya une sorte de
ratio entre le nombre de personnes qui
rentrent en réanimation un temps donné
et la population dont ils sont issus qui
est la population sur lesquels
finalement il ya eu c'est le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations en sachant
qu'on admet qui a à peu près x % qui
rentrent en réanimation
donc tout ça pour dire comme on part
avec quelque chose dedans corps qui
n'est pas totalement consolidé jeu il
faut vraiment fait très faire attention
à ce que je vais vous dire mais qui est
plutôt de l'ordre de 2 voilà de 10000 ou
de 15000 nouvelles contaminations qui
serait en train de tourner à partir de
la mi-mai ou de la femme et c'est à dire
jeudi cet ordre d'idées pour vous
montrer que ensuite les outils qu'il
faut mettre en face pour à la fois des
pistes et isolé de trouver les contacts
et bien ces outils doivent être adaptés
en termes opérationnels à ce à peu près
à ce chiffre alors si mais modélisateurs
était avec moi aujourd'hui ils
pousseraient décrit en disant mais
pourquoi tu leur dis tout ça il faut
faire très attention etc
mais je comprends bien qu'il faut un
moment donné comme se mouiller un peu
pour que cook on essaie tous d'avoir un
petit exercice de d'intelligence et de
compréhension serait ce qu'est ce qui va
être possible ou pas possible si je vous
annonçais qu'il y avait 150 me de
nouvelles contaminations chaque jour en
france à partir de mi-mai tout numérique
du monde ça ne ferait pas alors c'est
sûr la période de sortie du confinement
c'est à dire c'est à dire passer sur une
période mettons demi mais un essai sur
deux jours c'est par jour c'est par jour
et par jour tel sens de ma question
vous voyez que quand on dit que
l'épidémie s'est réduite elle s'est
réduite mais c'est pas elle est loin
d'avoir disparu
alors après il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup d'inconnues ça c'est le modèle
bon après
il ya l'été qui arrive quand on regarde
l'histoire des grandes épidémies
elles se sont toutes qualités et elles
ont toutes en partie repris en septembre
pour des raisons qu'on comprend pas bien
il ya des relations avec eux avec le
climat avec l'humidité qui existe et
puis surtout il ya de très grandes
disparités
c'est à dire qu'on va sortir mi mai ça
je vous ai donné un chiffre global pour
la france à une supposition mais
évidemment le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations va toujours demeurer plus
important en région parisienne parce
qu'on était parti de plus haut et on va
descendre
ok mais en descendant seront restera
plus haut est toujours dans sud ouest
qui lui a bénéficié d'un taux initial
qui était plus bas il a été confiné
donc le taux descend encore plus bas et
donc ils vont avoir une vitesse de virus
qui va être plus de renouvellement du
virus qui va être plus faibles tout
d'ailleurs au passage des questions
qu'on abordera pas aujourd'hui mais que
fait-on aussi au moment de la sortie du
confinement sur les pc les les questions
de communication interrégionale donc
voilà donc voilà en gros ce que ce que
nous allons avoir à ce deuxième élément
et qui ne relèvent pas du numérique mais
que je tiens à vous faire part de de
cela j'ai trois points pige après je
laisserai la parole et moi le deuxième
élément c'est que quelle population nous
allons avoir devant nous quand nous
allons sortir du confinement
eh bien on peut de façon extrêmement
schématique diviser la france en trois
parties premièrement les personnes qui
sont les plus à risque de développer une
forme grave ça va rester c'est sur les
personnes les plus d'un certain âge
disons dans laquelle d'ailleurs je suis
c
donc dessus de 65 ou de 70 ans ce sont
les personnes qui ont des affections de
longue durée qui ont des multi
pathologie insuffisances respiratoires
cardiaques etc enfin les à l'idée et
puis ce sont des sujets jeunes ayant une
pathologie mais aussi aux baisse puisque
vous savez que c'est un facteur de
gravité pour les formes graves
alors tout ça ça fait dix-huit millions
de personnes donc de toute façon
numérique au pad numérique
nous avons à la sortie du confinement 18
millions de personnes qui sont à risque
d'être contaminé et de continuer à
développer une forme au gras donc ses 18
millions de personnes c'est parasco et
bien on continuera le confinement dans
des conditions pour combien de temps je
ne sais pas en attendant qu'on trouve
peut être un médicament préventif mais
il faudra poursuivre le confinement
parce qu'elles sont à risque de
développer une forme grave deuxièmement
il y allait y aller car il ya les 50
millions de français plus jeunes
beaucoup moins à risque de développer
fut finalement faisant pouvant faire un
kobe dans des conditions je dirai tout à
fait raisonnable chi chi chi son équipe
et qui pose la question de ba de la
remise dans une heure une certaine forme
d'activités et avec le questionnement
plus particulier des plus jeunes filles
qui est une question qui est un peu à
part
puis il ya une troisième population qui
est environ un million de personnes qui
sont les sdf les personnes en grande
précarité
un certain nombre de migrants sur
lesquels on a très peu de données il
vous avez vu qu'il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de
deux mouvements beaucoup de notes
concernant ces populations les plus les
plus fragiles mais somme toute on a très
peu de dates
si vous me demandez la prévalence du coc
vide dans ces populations il n'y a
aucune bonne étude actuellement qui
permet tout à fait de le réaliser
donc alors les questions qui vont se
poser lors de la sortie du confinement
vous voyez bien que déjà on a 17 à 18
millions de personnes qui sont autistes
en jeu or dans ces personnes est sûre je
vais retomber sur mes pieds par rapport
au numérique il ya les personnes âgées
et j'entendais tout à l'heure avec
raison la présidente de la cnil
j'avais une oreille qui était comme ça
et mais c'est une des choses que j'avais
aussi dit le csn depuis longtemps
n'oublions jamais qui en france 18
pierce 18 % de personnes qui sont hors
du numérique
mais il s'avère que parmi ces personnes
il ya justement les personnes les plus
âgées et les personnes justement
migrantes et et sdf qui sont donc il y
en a une partie qui va être déjà confiné
pour des raisons de de précarité de
risque de risque médical plus important
alors maintenant comment avec que ce que
ce que vous avez est-ce qu'on a deux
aces comme à une idée finalement sur ok
mais on sort de là avec quelle est la
fraction de français qui a déjà été
contaminées par le col vite quand on va
sortir quand on va sortir du du
confinement et
eh bien là vous savez on dit que les
données très très préliminaires mais je
pense qu'elles sont maintenant c'est
solide
on est capable de mesurer avec des
nouvelles sérologie c'est à dire c'est
pas de diagnostic de que vides mais
c'est la recherche d'anticorps comme un
sérum diagnostic de rugby ou de ou
d'hépatite et on est capable de
distinguer les patients des personnes
séropositives pour le colis des sirops
négative et c'était sont en train d'être
finalisés mais on aura on a démarré à 0
tests début mars on a on tourne
actuellement à trois ou quatre mille
tests en ait encore des avec des tests
de pasteur ou de certains laboratoires
je dirais de recherche mais il ya
beaucoup de tests commerciaux qui sont
en train d'arriver ils sont en train
d'être évalués
j'ai pas de doute il certains d'entre
eux vont très bien marché et donc on
pourra voir des plateformes d'elisa de
l'ordre de 200 mille trois cent mille
tests par jour qui permettront de faire
des sérologies et on a cru et j'ai cru
pendant un an il ya une quinzaine de
jours trois semaines que ça allait être
un élément fondamental qu'on serait
capable de distinguer les séropositifs
protéger et des séronégatifs non
protégés et vous allez voir que je vais
vous donner un grand bémol ce qui montre
bien que que ce que sur les technologies
il faut faire attention
le bémol il est premièrement que quand
on regarde dans des populations qui ont
déjà eu et et vis-à-vis de la première
vague comme l'oise ou comme l'est de la
france mais c'est vrai également ses
deux premières données chinoises ou des
premières données italiennes
on a un taux d'immunité populationnelle
qui est de l'ordre de 10 12% maximum
donc ça veut dire que
la première vague n'a finalement
contaminé qu'une fraction relativement
limité et qu'on ne peut pas compter
dessus je dirais en fait en termes de
protection
le deuxième élément c'est que et qui est
encore plus complexe et qui montrent
qu'il faut être vraiment ce virus et
c'est une vacherie
on est même en train de se poser la
question si quelqu'un qui a fait 1 que
vides etc est séropositif il est
véritablement si protégés que ça et si
on n'est pas dans train de se tromper
complètement en dix ans séropositives
qu'ovide protéger eh bien il ya
maintenant une série de 2,2 d'éléments
qui suggèrent qu'il ya peut-être un
réservoir pour ce virus qui al'effet
domaine de réactivation qui peuvent
arriver et que la notion simple qui
était de bon sens que j'ai eu un que
j'ai eu à il ya il ya quinze jours trois
semaines vécues sur laquelle je voyais
je pose un élément de réserve de dire eh
bien non c'est finalement nous ne savons
pas si réellement le fait d'avoir des
anticorps et est un élément absolue de
protection voyez les allemands veulent
développer un passeport serreau plus en
10 ans chez par la population les gens
qui s'en servent plus ils sont
tranquilles
et bien c'est on est on est nous mêmes
avec un point d'interrogation là dessus
je me vois pas le résoudre tout de suite
tout de suite
donc c'était pour c'était juste un
signal d' alerte générale pour vous
montrer qu' il faut il faut être
véritablement c'est très très prudent
donc voilà les éléments je vous ai mis
sur la table ce que nous allons avoir
finalement donc un virus qui va tourner
mais de façon nettement plus ralenti que
ce que nous avions des disparités selon
les régions
une immunité populationnelle qui va être
relativement faible une signification et
d'interprétation des tests des tests
anticorps qui ne contrairement à ce
qu'on pensait alors qu'on aura tous les
outils pour le faire parce que là c'est
autant on va arriver à peu près à 100
militants diagnostic par jour en termes
de pcr rt pour le diagnostic
autant en termes de d'anticorps
on pouvait passer à beaucoup plus alors
finalement et je vais essayer la parole
et méryl peau pour la suite
il est clair que dans cette période de
déconfinement on ne veut pas passer du
noir au blanc
mais on va passer ça va être extrêmement
progressif et on va passer du noir au
gris foncé et pour passer au gris grise
et il va falloir du temps et je pense
que notre vision l'état de moi de
l'ordre du 15 juillet puis que bon il
peut se passer les choses et qu'il y a
encore beaucoup d'inconnues
donc il ya une vision de stand by step
le le deuxième
le deuxième élément c'est que on est
quand même avec les chiffres que je vous
ai donné dans quelque chose qui doit
être pris avec beaucoup de prudence mais
qui suggère que on est avec des chiffres
qui permettrait d'avoir une stratégie à
la coréenne c'est-à-dire avec
l'utilisation d'un testing des patients
qui ont le moindre symptôme ou même qui
demande à être testé en disant je crois
être avoir été en prison dans le métro
en présence de telle personne et ses
deux ans je m'en étais il va falloir
tester ces c'est clair de vincent collet
ont peu inversement j'entends parfois
certains qui il faut tester la
population française non il n'y a pas un
pays qui est capable de tester 81 60 8
millions de personnes
c'est pas faisable il faudrait le
répéter en plus un donc ce n'est pas
faisable mais il faut être extrêmement
large sur les indications du testing et
donc ça on est on annoncera probablement
début mai à cent mille tests pcr par
jour même peut-être encore augmenté donc
se donner toute la mécanique et la
mécanistiques opérationnel qui est
majeure enquête et le l'on parle
toujours du numérique pour le tra singh
j'insiste mais je pense que même les
deux vous en parlait il ya le numérique
pour le rendu des résultats comme on
rend ton 100000 résultats par jour moi
je sais pas faire je sais cette boulot
de
de jean castex mais il a vraiment du
boulot parce que comment on rend 100000
résultats par je vaux pour pour la fois
les individus c'est un résultat assez il
faut qu'il y ait une signature de 2,2
d'un biologiste qui signe le résultat il
faut que ça soit rendue à la personne il
faut que ça soit rendue au niveau
national pour qu'on ait une idée de ce
que devient l'immunité populationnelle
où le nombre de nouvelles de nouveaux
infectés puisque c'est une chose que
nous n'avions pas en france jusqu'à
maintenant
donc vous voyez qu'il ya des contraintes
et dans la vie si ce qu'on sortira dans
dans les semaines qui viennent sur sur
les stratégies de déconfinement on ne
peut pas sortir du déconfinement s'il
n'y a pas un certain nombre de prérequis
majeures qui doivent être là qui sont
des des pré-requis techniques et
opérationnelles ainsi le reste c'est du
c'est du vent si on a si on n'est pas
capable de mettre 100 points c'est vrai
pour le numérique c'est vrai pour les
autres points et puis alors par ailleurs
et je laisse la parole est libre il on a
comme en caisse qui a été fait
réellement corps et le fantasme un peu
de la corée qui qui semble qui équipe
qui pourrait suggérer pour grand public
voilà avec le numérique on va tout
régler
la réponse est non réponse est non
l'accord est bien sûr à utiliser le
numérique mais le tout numérique qui n'a
été utilisé que que finalement
essentiellement sur sur singapour en
corée il avait une armada jeu une
brigade de 20000 personnes qui étaient
là pour traquer entre guillemets
immédiatement allé repérer la personne
traqué ensuite avec l'outil numérique en
partie les contacts prendre cette
personne
regardez son statut regardez si elle
pouvait rester en famille ou si elle
pouvait ensuite aller si elles devaient
être isolés
c'est à dire si c'est de l'humain qu'il
ya derrière ça nous ne l'avons pas en
france c'est à dire c'est si on veut
utiliser le numérique il faut qu'il y
ait cette brigade entre guillemets on
peut l'appeler autrement une plate forme
etc
nous ne l'avons pas en france et si on
l'a pas en france ça ne marchera pas et
il faut il faut pas croire que le que
l'histoire du numérique va tout
et brille le peut-être lyon sera mes
propos mais je suis là pour vous pour
vous donner mon impression s'il n'y a
pas de l'humain et c'est plutôt
rassurant quand même s'il n'ya pas cette
force humaine qu'on est capable de
mettre en place ça le fera pas et on va
se planter et il faut pas croire que
c'est avec le numérique on va tout à
voir donc j'insiste là dessus parce que
l'interprétation de ce qui a été réalisé
en corée il ya un peu du fantasme et il
avait de l'humain voilà bah écoute et
merci beaucoup je voulais vous donner le
paysage beaucoup c'est toujours
passionnant d'avoir un exposé et
synthétique qui repose se re la
description des principales
problématiques et j'apprécie que vous
ayez commencé et conclut par cette mise
en garde
un dispositif aussi intelligent soit il
ne peut pas réussir tout seul c'est un
ensemble de mesures qui nous permette
d'encercler l'épidémie est de la réduire
donc je pense que le moment est venu de
donner la parole à monsieur wang
monsieur wang vous avez donc la parole
pour atterrir sur le sujet du numérique
mais enfin il est le paysage est déjà
bien tracé
merci mme bellon jours à tous oui pour
venir en écho et en complément des
propos du professeur delfraissy
et je voudrais préciser jeu suivante
donc le numérique aujourd'hui tel que
moi je les lance l'entendre le la
réponse sanitaire et de santé publique à
cette crise d'assez timide et miss est
comme elle est professeur delfraissy un
outil qui vient en appui des forces
humaines des professionnels de santé
pour qu'ils puissent faire correctement
leur travail à accomplir leur mission
compte tenu de deux caractéristiques des
virus comme dans tous compris sa
virulence et sa vitesse et donc le
numérique vient aider ce que humainement
c'est très difficile à faire c'est à
dire qu'il vient permettre aux humains
d'aller vite et de le faire dans des
volumes dans des volumes considérables
donc sur tout un parcours
d'accompagnement et de
et de sanitaires et de de santé
aujourd'hui ça la santé et puis dans
tout les hôpitaux publics privés
énormément d'initiatives qui ont qui ont
émergé et qui sont ou ont été mis sur le
terrain une que je peux citer ainsi je
reprends le parcours la première c'est
que quand vous avez des symptômes que
vous ne savez pas si c'est vous et
éventuellement de positif c'est de
pouvoir en fait être orientés pouvoir
décrire vos symptômes et être augmenté
typiquement la numérique permet de
pallier à quelque chose qui ne
marcherait pas si tout le monde appelle
le samu ou les pompiers ou son médecin
pour prier un échange humain sur les
symptômes
ça ne passe pas à l'échelle ça ne marche
pas qu'est ce qui a été fait par exemple
il ya un consortium d'acteurs privés et
publics qui a mis au point un
questionnaire d'orientation très bien
fait que le ministère de la santé a
regardé avec les professionnels à la
valider a poussé à tout le monde et
aujourd'hui par exemple vous avez quand
vous faites quand vous allez quand vous
avez des symptômes que vous allez sur
maladies coronariennes ce point fr les
avoir sur votre mobile ou sur votre
ordinateur à répondre à une trentaine de
questions et à la fin ça permettra
d'avoir un conseil très précis sur ce
que vous devez la paix tout de suite de
15 à ce que vous devez contactez votre
médecin traitant ou est-ce que vous
devez simplement surveiller l'évolution
de vos seins tall sall le numérique
permet de détailler à ce besoin à la
fois de vitesse d'accessibilité et de
volumétrie et permettrait d'ailleurs aux
personnes qui ne vont pas être à l'aise
avec un tel système de l pouvoir accéder
par téléphone à quelqu'un parce que les
services et fille ne sera pas saturer
donc typiquement ce que serveur notation
il est sur le numérique
mais il est aussi accessible par le
numéro vert mis en place par le
gouvernement
il est accessible par un qui va vous
déroulez le même questionnaire tous est
harmonisé et donc une fois qu en la
séparant à sion vous avez la question
effectivement de l'accès aux tests et
donc quand ils seront quand des
volumétries considérable citepa
professeur delfraissy de plusieurs
centaines de milliers par jour
eh bien comment
toutes ces informations sont transmises
en temps réel aux personnes concernées
pour qu'elles puissent tout de suite
prendre les dispositions qui s'imposent
et puis deuxième élément comment elles
peuvent être orientés correctement par
les pouvoirs publics par les autorités
sanitaires pour prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent aussi et ne pas rester seuls
isolés dans ce contexte est ce que je
dois est-ce que je peux rentrer chez moi
au risque de contaminer peut-être les
membres de mon sacré mialet ce qu'il
faut que j'aille ailleurs que dois-je
faire sa demande avant du numérique sa
demande d'abord de l'humain est d'abord
des gens qui puissent orienter et
accompagner
ensuite vous avez la question une fois
que je suis malade comment je vais être
suivi sur un plan médical sûr que ça
sature l'offre de soins c'est pour ça
que par exemple à la pêche
et il ya une solution qui a été mise en
place s'appelle co vie d'homme et qui
permet une forme de télésurveillance qui
permet aux personnels de santé de
l'ap-hp d'être en relation continue avec
leurs patients qui restent à domicile il
ya un suivi comme ça c'était aussi fait
par exemple je crois à bordeaux avec une
application qui s'appelle l'ange gardien
et donc ça veut dire que sur toute la
chaîne on est capable grâce au numérique
le lien épaulé de venir faire passer à
l'échelle les professionnels dans le
suivi et l'orientation de vie des
concitoyens
l'hawaiien entre barak est très
important compte tenu des
caractéristiques du virus
c'est la détection des cas positifs et
la détection des cas contact
c'est-à-dire toutes les personnes qui
ont pu être contaminés pendant la
période d'incubation où un cas positif
est contagieux et qui ensuite se font
que le virus se transmet à très grande
vitesse est donc l'enjeu là sans parler
du numérique c'est d'identifier le plus
vite possible
ces personnes et pouvoir le plus vite
possible les accompagner les orienter
pour qu'elle puisse prendre passer la
bonne information pour qu'elle puisse
prendre la bonne décision pour elle même
pour leurs familles et pour tous
voilà donc ce qu'on a regardé c'est que
incertain donc cette force sanitaire
aujourd'hui
elle ne passe pas à l'échelle de la
quérulence de ce virus et du nombre de
personnes contaminées
donc elle peut marcher sur comme elle a
marché sur un lycée dans l'oise ou sur
un village comme contamines montjoie
mais à l'échelle du pays cette force
sanitaires elle n'existe pas il faut la
créer
premièrement ça c'est pas ma partie mais
et deuxièmement voir si on peut
l'équiper l'outiller d'un de solutions
technologiques comme le numérique pour
qu'elles puissent faire correctement le
travail dans les conditions des chaînes
acquises et c'est là que c'est là que le
numérique le numérique intervient et
alors on a regardé un certain nombre de
solutions mises en oeuvre dans des pays
et donc vous avez à peu près sur les
murs et sur les pays qui ont mis le
beaucoup de moyens humains et
technologiques sur cette question de
l'identification et d'accompagnement des
cas contacts vous avez un salon des
réponses à ces différentes d'ailleurs
donc quand tu es mise en place en corée
par exemple taïwan en chine en israël 1
singapour beaucoup pays d'asie deux
villes d'asie ont mis des mesures en
place tout de suite du fait de
l'expérience acquise l'an passé avec
sarce en 2003 un puits et puis avec le
virus en 2008 et donc eux ils ont toutes
la même stratégie
pas de trous dans la raquette entre le
moment où quelqu'un est positif a pu
contaminer et le moment où les personnes
sont malades et sont suivis par le le
système de soins et veut et 200 en jeu
je continue mais je vous laisse
l'interrompre ainsi
non nous sommes attentifs à vos voitures
ont progressé vers ce qui fait
effectivement de l'actualité alors
justement quand on regarde ce qui a été
mis en place dans les pays asiatiques en
terme de santé publique et de 2,2
disposition de police sanitaire est
comme ça vous avez une palette de
réponses où il faut isoler le plus vite
possible les personnes simplement donc
par exemple en corée
les gens seront enclines à domicile
strictement en israël aussi au vietnam
je crois qu'ils sont placés dans des
centres de rétention sanitaire avec ce
que cela implique en termes de privation
de liberté
c'est difficile ça dépend des cas et
donc vous avez là la palette d'outils
alors ce qu'on a lu pour entrer dans le
vif du sujet on a vu plusieurs plusieurs
solutions mises en oeuvre
il ya des solutions qui ne demandent pas
consentement aux gens et les solutions
qui s'appuient sur le gps il ya des
solutions qui s'appuient sur le
monitoring extrêmement intrusif du
smartphone des individus et de celui et
puis donc on l'a vu ces solutions on a
vu leur efficacité
comment vous dire personnel mais j'étais
pas le seul à partager sa débat on les
connaît ça nous a paru assez loin de ce
que on a envie de faire et de ce qu'on
sait faire et puis surtout les autorités
sanitaires et les chercheurs en
épidémiologie qui en compte qu'ils ont
publiées papier de recherche sur
l'importance du groupe du traçage de
compte deux cas contacts via des
solutions numériques n'ont jamais abordé
ces questions et notamment il ya un
papier qui fait référence qui était
publié par une équipe neuve et d'oxford
qui n'ont jamais parlé de quatre duels
géolocalisation c'est donc le besoin
exprimé par les autorités sanitaires
sur des outils qui viendrait augmenter
là l'efficacité opérationnelle force
sanitaire s'appuyer sur des solutions
qu'on n'a pas vues différentes qu'on a
vu dans un seul pays pour l'instant qui
singapour donc une solution la plus
proportionnée possible la plus
minimaliste qui s'en tient à la
fonctionnalité la plus essentielle pour
aider les équipes sanitaires assurent
leur travail qui est de permettre à
quelqu'un de savoir qu'il est un cas
contacts il a possiblement été
contaminés du fait de sa proximité avec
un cas devenu positif est que cette
personne puisse de manière la plus
facile et le plus fluide possible être
en relation avec les autorités
sanitaires d'accompagnement et
d'orientation pour avoir les bons
conseils prendre les bonnes dispositions
elle suivit suivre ces symptômes le cas
échéant et puis ensuite être insérée
dans le parcours de soins si ces
sinistres voilà et donc du fait de cette
à la fois de cette recommandation de la
communauté des chercheurs en
épidémiologie qui modélise en fait un
pas que ça scop 2 et 2019 et de ce qui
avait été mis en place à singapour ont
commencé à travailler sur sûr sur cette
hypothèse en lien avec les autorités
même sous le pilotage de les autorités
de santé on a été amené à travailler sur
ces hypothèses sous de pilotage des
autorités de santé vous parlez du comité
scientifique n'ont alors pas bon
j'aurais dû préciser effectivement j'ai
aujourd'hui je le fais exprès je le fais
exprès de poser la question de manière
expresse parce qu'il ya une ambiguïté
dans votre propos et je tiens quand même
a souligné l'exigence d'une indépendance
du comité scientifique il est là
justement pour éclairer les autorités
sanitaires
il n'est pas en quelque sorte le
laboratoire d'étude des dispositifs
gouvernementaux pour la remise emploi
c'est comme ça que je le comprends moi
si je prends mes rêves et des demandes
conseil scientifique monsieur vous avez
la parole merci oui si je prends ma
casquette de membre du conseil du
conseil scientifique je suis j'ai un
retrait mineur au sein du conseil
scientifique évidemment métier déclaré
mes collègues sur capacités numériques
théoriques et pratiques dans le cadre de
cette crise pour pouvoir éclairer leurs
décisions qui sont avant tout des
décisions fondées sur l'état de la
science médicale et le et de benno
logique ensuite j'ai une une deuxième
carrière de monsieur le professeur
delfraissy veut intervenir et je vous
redonne tout de suite la parole pour
vous nous parler de votre deuxième
casquette nord juste pour dire que vous
savez que le conseil sont typiques c'est
s'est créé en plusieurs parties que nous
avons eu des entrants et en particulier
avec une nomination suite à la loi de
deux crises sanitaires une mission par
le président du sénat et par le
président de l'assemblée nationale et
j'ai souhaité finalement pour un comité
scientifique il est je ne suis pas je
suis pas étendre là-dessus mais il est
très pluridisciplinaire long du
fondamental de la clinique aux sciences
humaines et sociales et j'ai souhaité
faire rentrer lors de ce
de cette nomination possible à la fois
quelqu'un de la société civile parce que
je trouvais que c'était très important
qu'on est quelqu'un de la société civile
et ça et donc ça a été le cas et en
particulier par le par le président du
sénat
et puis quelqu'un également qu'ils
puissent qu'ils puissent rentrer et qui
nous guide dans le numérique puisque on
voyait bien que et des mois il l'a bien
rappelé que sur les différents points du
numérique on était avec des
questionnements et donc on avait besoin
de quelqu'un et dans le même temps
aymeric vous vous vous donnera sa
situation en même temps que le
solliciter pour ce être positionné dans
le conseil scientifique
le secrétaire d'état au numérique le
solliciter pour une coordination entre
guillemets d'une réflexion numérique au
sein du dudu des ministères voilà ils
brisent je vous laisse j'ai voulu
préciser ça il nous messieurs voir donc
vous avez la parole oui merci oui donc
en fait un très concrètement dans le 18
mars
gg sans être en contact avec le secret
est allumée riquet le conseil
scientifique quelques jours précédents
j'ai commencé spontanément avec des amis
d'anciens collègues à titre personnel à
travailler à regarder ce qui se passe en
corée à faire à une forme de et huiles
de synthèse et j'ai ensuite envoyé ce
document de synthèse notamment sur un
modèle que rien elle s'appelle facile
avec qui j'ai travaillé sur le numérique
dans le cadre de fonctions passées et
aussi au cabinet enfin c'est vrai qu'au
est en fait tant de manières
concomitante les deux m'ont proposé de
continuer à les éclairer sur ces
questions et à regarder ce qui se
passait dans un contexte où à l'époque
toute l'administration complètement
mobilisé sur la crise les surcoûts
retard mais elle n'était pas du tout
encore en train de penser à l'après
confinement parce que je précise que sur
le traçage de contact comme ça ne
ça ne fonctionne sur un plan théorique
une fois que l'épidémie est maîtrisé et
que le nombre de cas est et est donc est
ce que des procédés pourrait pour être
tout à fait clair et bien comprendre
votre fonction le travail que vous
faites pour le secrétariat d'état vous
le faites sous quel statut à quel titre
alors j'ai été missionné par e-mail le
24 mars par le directeur de cabinet
adjoint du premier ministre pour
continuer les études à thiais de
personnes étaient qualifiés bénévoles et
puis je lui parlais mission par une
lettre de mission signée par le
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
une 30 mars il missionne à titre de
parent a été qualifié bénévoles comme
comme conseil scientifique pour éclairer
l'état et ses services sur ce qui se
passe et coordonnée coordonner les
projets et l'expression de besoin d'à
côté scientifique et les projets
numériques et les solutions numériques
possibles qu'elles émergent de
l'écosystème numérique français privé
public
c'est ça le même aujourd'hui
donc c'était 7 litres que l'âge
intervient de manière très concrète sur
le projet de développement d'une
application de traçage de contact qui
serait mise à disposition du
gouvernement s'ils décident aide
je vous remercie donc monsieur le
président le conseil scientifique est
aux premières loges puisque
sont membres est également l'un de ceux
qui est appelée à configurer
l'éventuelle système qui serait qui
serait mis en place alors pouvez vous
aller un peu plus loin monsieur vendre
sur la description de ce système
oui donc aujourd'hui ce que le projet
qui et qui est développée donc pour vous
refaire la chronologie
en fait quand quand j'ai commencé à
regarder ces sujets il s'avère qu'il y
avait un projet européen qui avait
démarré sur des bases très proche de
singapour sur quelque chose qui à la
fois présenter le potentiel d'une
certaine caste et solitaire et qui en
même temps a été extrêmement attentifs
aux questions de respect de la
protection des données personnelles de
respect de l'anonymat et une
proportionnalité dans les technologies
qui seraient utilisés et donc on a
commencé comme ça prendre contact avec
ses invités
inria prendre contact avec ceux avec ce
projet et puis un certain nombre
d'acteurs aussi privé qui s'étaient
manifestés pour travailler sur ces
questions afin de contact avec ce projet
puis en fait il ne sommes arrivés à la
conclusion assez rapidement que avait
une pertinence il pouvait répondre un
certain nombre d'attentes sanitaires
mais aussi des attentes de transparence
et de respect d'un certain nombre de
libertés de libertés fondamentales
le projet a démarré comme ça de manière
très concrète est donc aujourd'hui vous
avez les équipes de l'inria qui
travaillent avec des équipes de
d'un institut fraunhofer l'allemagne est
aussi des équipes de l'école politique
qui fait parler de lausanne chercheurs
travaillent sur protocole qui est qui
serait utilisé pour les applications
si je reviens sur les spécifications
telles que l'on était pour l'instant sur
lesquels on travaille pour l'instant
c'est une application qui n'utilisent
que nous tous c'est une application qui
ne demande aucune donnée personnelle pas
d'état civil mais pas le numéro de
téléphone pour l'instant c'est pas
trancher est ce qu'on a besoin pour les
autorités sanitaires de deux mots des
livres deux téléphones par et c'est donc
une application ça a été très bien
décrits précédemment mais je vais je
vais répéter il application bluetooth
qui est installé sur une base volontaire
à l'est par les personnes qui active
donc cette le bluetooth sur la télé leur
téléphone et qui leur permet dans leur
parcours quotidiens d'enregistrer de
manière anonyme qui l ont croisé de
manière qualifiés et le modèle de santé
de calibrage cette qualification est
encore encore en attente de indication
de la part de la communauté scientifique
dont quelle équipe il ya des personnes
les chercheurs de l'inserm de l'institut
pasteur de santé publique france et du
ministère de la santé qui sont travaille
dessus
est ce que un contact aka contact s'est
il faut qu'il faut que les deux
personnes étaient à moins de deux mètres
moins de 1 mètre 5 minutes c'est digne
de sa rencontre avec les et les clés
réserve les contraintes que vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure le président
est-ce que les gens se tournent ce soit
ceux se fondent aux ados est ce que
certains masques pas l'autre etc
c'est des contraintes que les situations
de combat équivalente et donc la
personne qui est au travail ou et dans
la rue ou et dans les transports en
commun ou à faire ses courses
eh bien le téléphone va enregistrer des
identifiants anonyme
et tout ça ne reste sur le téléphone de
chacun et si à un moment donné quelqu'un
et testés positifs et que c'est qu'il le
déclare dans l'application l'application
le protocole prévoit que l'ensemble des
identifiants anonyme que cette personne
testée positive à croiser soir sera
remonté sur un serveur pourquoi ce
serveur notifie ces personnes voilà
notifie les applications et donc que les
personnes qui sont devenues des cas
contactez puissent être informés
donc je fais une précision ce protocole
là parce qu'au départ les allemands et
les suisses avaient pas travailler sur
quelque chose comme ça et d'ailleurs
google apple non plus ce qui pose la
question le statut de séropositivité de
quelqu'un n'ai jamais transmis personnes
dont donc tout est anonyme et mais en
plus ce statut n'est jamais transmis à
aucun serveur ni rien il reste sur le
téléphone
et ensuite il disparaît le jour où
l'application est issu tribus et un
petit prix mettre tout moment par
l'utilisateur et donc parce que ce qui
compte sur un plan sanitaire si j'ai
bien compris ce que m'ont dit ce que
nous ont dit les médecins et des
personnes experte en la matière ce qui
compte c'est uniquement que là que le
cas contacts soient informés qu'il est
potentiellement contaminés pour qu'ils
puissent se suivre ces symptômes se
faire tester et puis prendre les mesures
d'isolement qui s'imposent pour stopper
la chaîne de transmission du laus
je vous remercie suivant je ne suis pas
sûr de bien comprendre ce point mais
c'est par méconnaissance des dispositifs
techniques vous dit
le statut de séropositivité de la
personne n'ai jamais transmis
mais qu'est ce que ça signifie
parce que en même temps la personne par
bienveillance va alimenter le serveur
par une information tout simple c'est
qu'il est porteur du virus
et ça déclenche ensuite enchaîne
l'information des personnes qui ont été
en contact avec le porteur du virus donc
sa séropositivité est bien remonté sur
le serveur mais vous voulez sans doute
dire que son anonymat est préservé
non non absolument et d'ailleurs je
tiens à saluer le travail est très
pertinent des équipes inria parce que ce
sont elles qui ont imaginé ce protocole
qui a ensuite convaincu les allemands
les chercheurs pour pour pour pour ce
protocole
il n'y a pas besoin de transmettre le
statut de séropositivité à un serveur
pour notifier les personnes qu'il faut
notifier il suffit de transmettre aux
serveurs les les identités anonyme des
personnes qu'il faut le modifier
je sais que c'est un peu difficile à
comprendre qu'est-ce qu'on leur notifie
à ces personnes alors on leur notifie
qu'elles ont été
qu'elles ont été en contact qualifié
avec quelqu'un qui vient d'être testé
positif et donc elles sont
potentiellement elle aussi sera positif
si jamais le virus est transmis à a été
transmis avec l'aisance de contacter les
elles ne savent pas qui c'est d'ailleurs
le savent vraiment plus ne sait pas on
ne sait pas quand on ne sait pas ou
parce que le gps ne marche pas on ne
sait rien à part la seule information
qui compte sur un plan sanitaire qui est
que je suis peut-être positif est que
pour arrêter pour me protéger pour me
soigner pour protéger les postes proches
et pour protéger les autres je dois
prendre les dispositions qui s'imposent
tout de suite pour stopper cette chaîne
de transmission extrêmement virulente et
et rapide due aux donc faire tomber
c'est le fameux les réservoirs à moins
de 1
aucune autre information que le fait
d'avoir été en contact pendant une durée
qui est prévu par l'application avec une
personne qui s'est révélé séropositifs
ni quand ni où ni dans quelles
conditions évidemment je vous remercie
oui exactement comment ça ça ne
servirait ça ne servirait à rien pour le
besoin sanitaire qui est de pouvoir que
permettre à cette personne de prendre
les mesures qui s'imposent
et puis mentalement d'être orientés par
le système de soins forcément et alors
là je me tais je me tourne vers le
président du conseil et scientifique
la personne qui bénéficient de cette
information
c'est une information qui va entraîner
quel type de disposition de sa part de
votre point de vue j'ai juste deux
choses pour dire que sur les mesures
très général de deux sorties du
confinement le conseil scientifique eux
souhaitent qui est une tentative
d'harmonisation européenne ont eu cap
aussi européenne et ce pour une double
raison
[Musique]
cécile une part que si on si on doit
avoir des approches technologiques elles
soient pas trop différent d'un pays à un
autre
et deuxièmement il ya depuis que de
début mars
nous distinguons bien ce qu'ils sont des
décisions politiques
l'acceptabilité des français des
citoyens et la réalité de ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
il faut c'est que c'est la même chose
qu'en médecine entre un médecin qui
prescrit un patient qui acceptent le
traitement et l'observance plus ou moins
grande à ce traitement est ce qui compte
finalement c'est le résultat final c'est
bien comment ça va se passer sur le
terrain et donc qui nous paraît que sur
ces sujets hautement sensible le fait
d'avoir une solution partagée sinon
commune de deux ou trois très grands
pays européens avec des cultures qui
sont un peu différentes des visions des
des niveaux des niveaux d'infections qui
sont d'ailleurs différents permettrait
peut être probablement pour en
particulier nos concitoyens français qui
légitimement se poser un certain nombre
de questions mais de dire que vous voyez
c'est ce qu'on vous propose n'est pas
seulement une décision du gouvernement
français est quelque chose qui a été
réfléchi à plusieurs sur plusieurs
étages qui proposait en même temps aux
concitoyens allemand henry des nuances
peut-être 1 au suisse avec des nuances
puisque vous avez vu que le le pfl est
également de dessus eh bien nous paraît
très à moyens finalement d'acceptabilité
qui serait plus important que si on
faisait uniquement hill stratégies à la
française comme on sait faire d'habitude
et l'a déjoué un peu la carte de
l'europe qui jusqu'à maintenant au
passage d'ailleurs a été peu au
rendez-vous de cette réponse qu vide
en tout cas sur les aspects sur les
aspects de rechercher et sanitaires
ensuite pour répondre à votre question
cette proposition qui est faite elle
rejoint deux de recommandations qu'on
conques était propre alors cette fois ci
au haut comité scientifique après une
maj la gueule
elle est en elle est en jeu on n'est pas
là pour dire il faut prendre telle ou
telle proposition c'est pas l'objet on
est là pour donner des grands principes
et les grands principes c'était
évidemment ce double volontariat un
volontariat de rentrée l'application de
ne pas la rentrée et et ensuite un
volontariat de qui qui existe là vous
l'avez bien vu c'est le niveau 2 cc de
transmission du fait qu'on est con est
diagnostiqué positif au passage les mots
ont été employés de qu'on est
séropositif non on est diagnostiqué
positif 1 restant bien c'est ça le c'est
ça l'enjeu 1 on est diagnostiquée comme
étant positif et ensuite on transmet
l'information sur le reste s'il fallait
la différence et sa région à les tests
il ya deux types de tests
la rt pcr qui permet que vous avez une
su penser avoir des symptômes on vous
fait le prélèvement nasal et on ne
détecte de la rn virale tôt qu'on
détecte bien du virus et bien diagnostic
virologique tandis que quand on parle de
sérologie là c'est une prise de sang et
on détecte des anticorps ça veut dire
que vous avez été un moment donné en
contact avec le virus avec les nuances
que je vous ai donné tout à l'heure mais
là on parle bien de l'utilisation du
test diagnostique de la pcr de la rt pcr
qu'ovide et c'est ça le diagnostic il ne
repose que là-dessus et c'est à peu près
la capacité qu'on va avoir
nîmes est de faire cent mille tests par
jour à peu près en france avec très
large en s'appuyant la fois sur le
public et et sur le privé voilà monsieur
le président je reviens est vraiment
pardon de vous poser des questions et
aussi pratique mais pour terminer la
description de tous les enchaînements
l'individu on a détecté la présence du
virus
il utilise son application et
l'application va permettre de contacter
toutes les personnes qui auront été
rencontré par cet individu un temps
suffisant et qui eux-mêmes dispose de
l'application bien entendu mais que
sera-t-il recommandait à ces personnes
de faire quant à leur sort ont reçu
cette information
c'est une très bonne question c'est
vraiment c'est ça montre bien la
jonction qui doit y avoir entre le
numérique et l'humain et donc on revient
bien à cette notion de pour accompagner
sa et c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs en corée et ou ne sera pas
tout dans dans le tout numérique en
france
il faut qu'ils aient cette fameuse
brigade ou plateformes opérationnelles
qu'ils puissent à la fois immédiatement
contacté
les prendre en compte la personne la
personne qui a été détectée comme
positive faire un bilan avec elle voir
si dans quelles conditions elle est
prise en charge si elles nécessitent une
hospitalisation pas si elle nécessite
pas d'hospitalisation et les choses ne
sont pas encore formalisés
quelle attitude on a est-ce qu'il faut
la remettre en famille s'il y a une des
conditions sociétal qui le permettent
mais avec aussi des points
d'interrogation car on peut si on la
remet en famille malgré les précautions
malgré les les l'ensemble des mesures
qui peuvent être prises
on peut constituer des foyers familiaux
au contraire faut-il prendre une
décision générale une fois qu'on aura
dépister ces personnes de les mettre de
lise isolés pendant une période de x
temps probablement de semaine dans un
hôtel ou dans des structures haddock
d'isolement des personnes positives et
la question n'est pas tranchée
vous imaginez que c'est pas seulement la
vision ni des scientifiques ni la vision
uniquement des politiques et que les
citoyens ont quand même leur mot à dire
là dedans
ces jeux c'est autant les décisions
autres et on traitait très top d'armes
au début de l'épidémie parce qu'il y
avait urgence
autant sur ces questions là me
semble-t-il la société civile seront son
expression donc en gros il ya les deux
il ya les deux possibilités soit c'est
une décision générale de dire ces
personnes seront isolés dans des hôtels
et sauf circonstances particulières très
particulière on les laissera chez elle
mais vous voyez bien qu'on va la
distinguée avec selon des moyens
financiers ou selon les catégories
sociales c'est donc c'est je trouve ça
quand même avec un point d'interrogation
ou bien au contraire on a une vision qui
est plus lâches et qui dit ça sur au cas
par cas et le médecin de famille pour
art ou la perte ou la structure pourra
décider c'est sur la table et je nous
n'avons pas la réponse et monsieur le
président
celles qui ont rencontré alors voilà
donc versée dans la deuxième partie de
votre question péri sur les sur les
personnes qui ont qui ont rencontré
alors là me semble-t-il
il faut qu'elle soit au courant 2
il faut qu'elle lequel puis cela cette
fois-ci s'isoler et là me semble-t-il
il faut une très large utilisation des
tests c'est logique c'est pas forcément
où avec 15 du symptôme
c'est une vraie question mais ton bâton
m autant je sent bien qu'on va être
capable de faire d'utiliser les tests
très largement pour les personnes qui
ont des symptômes les fameux 100 mille
tests un par jour qui seront disponibles
où je vous disais même toute personne
qui réclamera un test bon pour un pas
mon avis il faut il faut être très large
ans la france a raté le le testing
on février et il faut il faut qu'on se
mette dans des conditions entre
guillemets mais elle a raté parce
qu'elle n'avait pas les moyens de le
faire je non pas de le dire mais il n'y
avait pas les tests pour le faire donc
il faut il faut que l'on soit dans des
conditions d'utilisation extrêmement
large
alors après sur faut-il aller et l'on
nous la capacité de tester très
largement les personnes contactent jeu
pour l'instant je réserve ma réponse
c'est work in progress
oui vous avez parfaitement expliquée
dans votre propos introductif qu'on
pourrait avoir la capacité technique de
faire peut-être deux à trois cents mille
tests mais vous devez au gîte a ajouté
qu' au moment du coup d confinement on
ne serait qu'à cent mille tests par jour
alors nous n'avons pas d'idée du nombre
de tests qui serait réellement
nécessaire mais non et ni même si pour
une personne qui a rencontré une
personne contaminée il suffira au moment
où il reçoit la formation de cette
rencontre de faire un test aussi devra
pas en faire un deuxième temps fort en
deuxième ça que je laisse je laisse
cette question à cette question sur la
table mais est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut refaire
mûrir la réflexion suffisamment vite
pour que l soit à maturité que le 11 mai
une occasion nous ayons les éléments de
la décision
écoutez il faut oui il faut il faut
puisque dans nous on est assez clair
dans sur sur la vie qui portera sur le
déconfinement il ya un certain nombre de
prérequis qui font que ces prérequis
doivent être installés qui sont d'erquy
à la fois du nombre de tests de l'outil
numérique choisit de la brigade de la
brigade dont je parlais et et de est une
véritable stratégie claire annoncé nos
concitoyens qui qui paie aimé et sur des
aspects pratico pratique est exactement
le type de questions que vous posez
est-ce qu'on a les chambres d'hôtel
comme on les maires de l'ensemble de
cette déclinaison qui ne relèvent pas du
comité scientifique
on n'est pas là on n'est pas du tout
opérationnel on n'a ni les moyens ni les
mets qui relève me semble-t-il plutôt de
la mission de de gens de jean castex qui
est pour eux pour mettre ces points et
on est très en lien avec un évidement
c'est bien clair mais à mon avis ça doit
être très clairement mis sur la table
est ce qu'on ne saura pas faire il
faudra le dire qu'on ne sait pas faire
et éventuellement s'il faut retarder de
quelques jours parce qu'on est pas prêt
il faudra retarder de quelques jours
parce qu'on n'est pas prêt non je suis
extrêmement claire du président je sais
que vous avez d'autres obligations nous
allons s'il le veut bien gardé monsieur
wang et vous libérer non sans vous avoir
chaleureusement remercié monsieur
waterblez ne veux pas vous laisser
partir sans avoir posé une question peut
être monsieur non parce qu'on est loin
d'eux
devon terrier ou pas vous avez comme
soulevé pas mal de problèmes et surtout
de cette brigade
en sortie pour la corée de vingt mille
personnes
l'accord aux essais 51 millions
d'habitants la france 67
donc c'est pas mieux le français presque
trente mille mais je citais les 20000
mais il faut que c'est une brigade qui
ont peut-être de trente mille personnes
ce que je pensais qu'elle a organisé le
20 mai mais le décalage qui voit les
bons depuis les débuts et bon vous
l'avez souligné le le virus va vite très
vite on a raté les masques quinze jours
trois semaines on y est maintenant on va
rivehaute est tout juste plus juste et
en sortie vous quel président du coni
scientifique
est-ce que vous avez préconisé de façon
urgente et en sachant d'avancé
cette brigade parce que et je devais
aller plus loin est-ce qu'il faut pas
sorti du confinement l'obligation du
masque quelle est la première protection
comme je vous ai vus arriver qui serait
nécessaire peut-être pour éviter ces
contacts parce qu'il faut te revient à
c'est un basique on a toujours un petit
décalage de temps entre le masque les
dépistages le côté opérationnel d'une
brigade
et est-ce qu'il faudra pas abandonnée
devant le ce que vous a exposé avec le
risque de ce virus
l'obligation pour se croiser pendant un
temps déconfinement le port du masque
obligatoire
on sera pas ont contraint pas si vous
l'avez à traquer les gens mais peut-être
que cette démarche-là obligera à éviter
de son côté trop facilement écouter on a
on a un avis qui est en cours de
l'élaboration de jeux pas mais je peux
j'ai été très clair
j'ai dit que le démarrage de cet avis
c'étaient les prérequis pour pouvoir
sortir du confinement
parmi les prérequis l'utilisation du
masque en étant bon et en effet je suis
partage votre analyse qui est ce lieu
c'est très difficile soyons tous un bhl
un mois le premier devant devant
l'extrême difficulté de donner des
éléments de réponse
et c'était pas facile facile que ça de
prévoir ce qui allait se passer
en début février et c'est donc aux
russes et on peut refaire l'histoire
mais c'était c'était quelque chose de
très compliqué mais essayons cette fois
ci de ne pas être derrière ça rejoint
votre réflexion mais d'être sinon devant
en tout cas d'être en même temps et
c'est c'est pour cela que vraiment le
pré requis et moi je suis extrêmement
clair si on n'a pas les prérequis il
faut il faut rester confinés et il
faudra il faudra il faudra rester une
semaine de plus confiné quelles que
soient les les les difficultés
sociétales et économiques que je perçois
comme comme tout citoyen mais pour que
ça ne reprennent pas il faut se donner
les moyens de ses ambitions
les affiches et et les données très
clairement nos citoyens qui sont qui
vont parfaitement comprendre sans
monsieur le président nous vous livrons
donc et maintenant je vais redonner la
parole soit monsieur waterblez s'il veut
poser des questions à monsieur wang et à
monsieur hervé qui ne manquera pas de
lui en poser puis nos collègues qui se
sont inscrits même en retirant mieux
simplement reprendre un peu ce qu'on a
eue avec la cnil sur le caractère
volontaire du recours à l'application
bien sûr donc comment vous allez
posséder pour eux ce consentement libre
et éclairé pour la formation
ce qui sera important et s'il possible
de voir des contreparties pour les
personnes qui qui utiliseront
l'application traçage sur tout et puis
ben on a le professeur a répondu sur la
sortie avec le dépistage puisque
apparemment on aura le nombre de tests
disponibles en sortie on parle de 100
mille et un peu plus
bon voila mais mes deux questions
suivantes je vais demander à monsieur
hervé de poser également ces questions
et vous répondrai
aux deux séries de questions monsieur
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur
j'avais eu plusieurs plusieurs
interrogations de la première c'est que
le coeur de de l'informel à
l'information la plus importante c'est
l'information qui est l'information
déclenchante c'est à dire j'ai été testé
positif aux copies de jeux pas
scientifique donc je veux pas faire
d'erreurs mais qui vérifie que cette
information est attestée et que la
personne sur son terminal qui va
déclencher la chose ne le fait pas à
mauvais escient ou parce qu'elles se
considèrent elles se tout diagnostic
elle même se disant tiens
gdg des symptômes qui me font penser à
et du coup je déclenche la chose que
c'est bien que le parallèle est
et la personne qui est diagnostiquée
positive et qui décideraient de ne pas
prévenir utiliser l'application pour
pour nom a bien compris là ça pose
d'autres difficultés en termes d'hommes
en termes de liberté je rejoins la
question de mon collègue dany wattebled
sur la question de la fra structure de
larmes de l'armada et aider et de ce que
nous devrions déclenchée en termes de
suivi moi je viens la haute-savoie donc
c'est le département qui a connu à la
fois les contamines montjoie et la balme
de sillingy entame de kloster et qui a
fait face et à gérer et à contenu et ses
deux clusters que plutôt bien d'ailleurs
mais avec des moyens humains absolument
absolument considérable donc voila c ces
deux questions une question sur
l'information déclenchement d une
question sur la phrase structure d'une
tour merci monsieur vous revenir oui
merci à présent à vos questions sur le
caractère obligatoire de l'équipe projet
n'a pas reçu de demande de la part des
pouvoirs publics de travailler sur le
caractère obligatoire de l'application
sur un plan technique le pas donc
aujourd'hui l'application sur un pan de
spécifications techniques elles seraient
installés librement par par un chacun
voilà par ailleurs je n'ai je n'ai vendu
aucun projet de diriger une obligation
réglementaire
enfin je un régime de l'obligation
particulier et d'ailleurs je moi je m'en
tiens aux propos publics de du
secrétaire d'état au numérique et du
lisa santé qui ont insisté sur le
caractère pas sûr en tout cas sur le
consentement absolue des personnes a
décidé d'installer ou pas cette
application
alors ça pose des questions en termes
d'efficacité mais voilà mais il ya
encore une fois ci à côté si cette
application vient bien en soutien d'une
force humaine considérable qui fait ce
travail là
c'est là le fait que tout le monde n'est
pas l'application posera des questions
d'efficacité de l'application seul mais
c'est l'efficacité globale qu'il faut
regarder sur la question de sur la
question de l'info déclenchante donc en
instant l'expression de besoin donc là
je vous parle en transparence de choses
qui ne sont pas arbitrées et qui sont
encore qui font encore l'objet de leur
élection juste pour vous pour vous dire
le projet il a formellement démarré il
ya moins de dix jours
donc voilà demandé dans des délais
records et on vit vraiment en avance 1
en avance en marchant à ce stade nous
travaillons sur une hypothèse qui n'est
pas arbitré qui est que il ya un
contrôle préalable du caractère positif
de de la suspicion de positivité de la
personne soit parce qu'il ya un test qui
dit qu'elle est positive soit parce que
à la suite d'un échange avec son maître
un médecin traitant sur ces symptômes il
est clair qu'elle est probablement
positive est elle donc s'il ya un
contrôle préalable qui ferait qu'elles
pourraient déclencher l'alertent sur son
application que sous contrôle
et sur un plan technique l'idée c'est
que en fait ce soit un professionnel de
santé laboratoires ou médecins ou
infirmiers qui donne un code un code un
code numérique ou un qr code aux
personnes pour qu'elles rendent dans
l'application
six de ces réponses monsieur hervé vous
vouliez poser une question
complémentaire ne répondait pas tout de
suite monsieur vente parce qu'ensuite je
vais donner successivement la parole à
monsieur richard à monsieur le comte à
monsieur collombat à madame benbassa à
monsieur kerrouche et à monsieur marc
dans cet ordre est donc vous aurez si
série de questions en plus de la
dernière question de monsieur hervé
j'énonce toutes ses interventions pour
que les collègues puissent s'y prépare
et met d'abord la parole est à monsieur
loïc hervé merci monsieur le président
monsieur j'avais une question importante
mais qu'il guide qui est une question
liée à la souveraineté
vous nous avez apporté un certain nombre
de d'informations très précieuse on aura
l'occasion je pense de revenir sur ces
questions cet après midi aux questions
gouvernement et demain avec l'audition
du ministre de l'intérieur
c'est une question absolument central
pour créer les conditions de la
confiance
vous n'ignorez pas que les gars fassent
sont déjà positionnés sur ces sujets on
n'a pas les cas présentent de la cnil
tout à l'heure qu'il s'agisse d'apple de
google d'autres d'autres gaf a
comment est-ce que sur l'hébergement des
données comment est-ce que sur les
briques logicielles utile à la
construction de l'application comment
sur un certain nombre de deux dimensions
techniques on garantit à nos
compatriotes qu'on est bien sûr une
application souveraine note qu'il ya une
volonté européenne je la salue
évidemment c'est absolument fondamental
mais quand est ce qu on garantit aux
anneaux à nos compatriotes qu'on est
bien dans une application conforme gpd
et qui garantit les libertés
individuelles comme c'est une une
exigence que le parlement vraiment vous
demande d'avoir nous j'ai eu mon cou à
la caméra
nous vous entendons monsieur richard et
nouveau salut encore sur la petite ne
vous voyons pas mais nous vous entendons
vous pouvez poser votre question
alors ma question est pour aujourd'hui
hors sujet et j'aurai de loin préféré
cher cette cet avis au président
professeur delfraissy
mais dans la loi qui prévoit une des
étapes importantes du retour à la
normale à savoir la poursuite de la vie
des collectivités locales nous avons
sous le terme à un rapport avant le goût
trop mais en vérité deux questions très
différent d'une part on demandera avant
cette date au comité scientifique de
porter une appréciation est dénoncée
éventuellement des précautions sur la
possibilité d'appeler les électeurs aux
urnes dans donc un grand nombre de
communes dont des communes peuple et
avec donc des bureaux de vote avec un
rassemblement de personnes
à la même date mais à mon avis dans un
autre rapport
et sur ce point là que je voudrais
mettre un post it pour le comité
scientifique et dirais la même chose au
gouvernement demain vous devez porter
une appréciation énoncé les précautions
pour savoir si on peut dans des salles
avec humour plus grande maîtrise
il risque de transmission réunir au
moins pour une fraction les conseils
municipaux pour installer les communes
les autorités communales et mettre fin à
la situation de dualité entre les
équipes sont plus en fonction
ils sont maintenus en fonction des
équipes et le poids sur lequel vous
réussissez c'est qu'il ya bien là en
réalité deux objets distincts avec des
enjeux sanitaires à petit à première vue
me paraissent très différent
quantitativement palier du passage à
l'échelle on exactement sur ce sujet là
de manière que le congrès scientifique
se prononce avec la plus grande clarté
sur la faisabilité d'une opération et de
l'autre alors qu'elles sont bien
différentes
merci je vous remercie et chers
collègues c'est une question en effet
très importante
je ne suis pas sûr que monsieur wang
pourra y répondre mais nous ferons nous
aussi porter directement auprès du
professeur delfraissy de cette attente
que le conseil scientifique se
prononcent spécifiquement sur les
conditions sanitaires requises pour que
les conseils municipaux puissent élire
les maires et les adjoints et pas
seulement sur la question du second tour
des élections municipales se sont bien
en effet des questions tout à fait
distincts monsieur le comte
oui bonjour vous vous m'entendez oui oui
oui merci monsieur le président d'alors
je voudrais saluer ce que le professeur
d'être ici a dit sur la nécessaire
réponse européenne est justement de ce
point de vue là je suis assez mal à
l'aise parce que lorsqu'on regarde la
situation
l'allemagne par rapport à la situation
française on a un nombre de cas près en
allant de nombre de cas confirmés qui
est très proche
par contre on a des conséquences en
terme de décès qui sont quatre à cinq
fois plus importante en france compte
tenu des difficultés qu'on a eu à mettre
en place un certain nombre de moyens en
terme de protection et de moyens
sanitaires et c'est donc
particulièrement préoccupant de voir
aujourd'hui discuter d'une application
qui limiterait la liberté des français
parce que il y à un manque de protection
alors je voudrais d'abord vous personnel
et qui n'a pas parce qu'elle a des
moyens sanitaires différents des nôtres
réussi le passage finalement de ce début
de crise est ce que l'allemagne fait
partie des pays européens qui
travaillent sur ce type d'applications
la deuxième chose c'est est-ce que cela
exigera que nous mettions en place dès
maintenant et pour longtemps une
politique différente d'accueil de
situation particulièrement délicate mais
aussi sanitairement parlant enfin
spécifiquement sûr sûr sûr sûr
l'application qui est envisagée parce
que si on parle de bluetooth on parle
d'appareil téléphonique
on ne parle pas de numéro de téléphone
on parle d'un dispositif bluetooth en
tant que tel est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire si c'est ou est ce qu'il faut à
chaque fois
finalement ce sera l'appareil qui sera
identifié par le numéro de téléphone
parce que finalement on peut aussi
imaginer des situations où des
structures qui voudraient garantir une
certaine sécurité sanitaire met en place
des dispositifs bluetooth à leur entrée
ou à l'intérieur de l'espace
donc en fait de la géolocalisation parce
qu'on sait où elles seront ce sera pas
des téléphones porté par des gens mais
installés à des endroits précis et
lorsqu'on
couple ça à d'autres systèmes et en
particulier à des systèmes de vidéo
surveillance surveillance autres
finalement on arrive à des systèmes
qu'ils peuvent être particulièrement
intrusif en termes de libertés
individuelles et de suivi donc je
voudrais savoir si vous êtes capable
d'assurer un certain nombre de garanties
sur ces sujets là voilà merci merci cher
collègue monsieur collombat j'aurai deux
questions à poser
la première concerne un point qui
étrangement d'ailleurs être à quoi était
vraiment évoqué dans notre conversation
dans notre dans nos échanges c'est le
problème du traitement alors qu'ici on
s'en tient à ce qui se dit dans les
médias ça va de bahia pour le traitement
se sentent pas à la verse
on sait qu'on peut sous certaines
conditions surtout si on commence à ses
tons avoir des résultats intéressants
ma question est la suivante est ce que
le est ce que le corps le conseil
scientifique fait une expertise des
traitements des traitements en cours
parce que on s'aperçoit à lire les
témoignages que selon les établissements
hospitaliers des pratiques de fait qui
sont qui sont différentes
ou est ce que me faut tout le monde fait
ce qu'il peut dans son coin ça c'est ma
première question est la deuxième la
deuxième question
après l'exposé très rassurant sur ce qui
n'a pas été fait depuis ce qui nous
reste pardon ce qui nous reste à faire
pour sortir du rhin confirmant c'est une
la question c'est la suivante
depuis qu'on sait qu'il ya quand même un
risque de pandémie à dire mois d'octobre
mois de novembre de l'année dernière et
le mois de mars où apparemment donc on a
décidé le confinant qu'est ce qu'on a
fait dans notre pays et ce qu'on a fait
il précisément nous semble
si l'on s'en tient à ce qui nous a été
dit tout quasiment reste à faire est ce
que je sais pas comment comment vous
voyez ça qu'est ce qui a été fait entre
ses dents ces quatre mois cinq mois il
nous a séparés du moment où ils ont les
gens formés ça il y avait un risque
sérieux mon cher que j'en ai terminé ne
transmettront de toutes vos questions au
professeur delfraissy mais peut-être
n'avez-vous pas été en lien avec nous
quand il a dû nous quitter le professeur
delfraissy n'est plus je suis avec vous
si monsieur lang s'il le souhaite depuis
quinze jours qu'il participe aux travaux
du conseil scientifique vous apportera
des éléments de réponse mais je pense
que ces questions très importantes que
vous posez ces questions essentielles
c'est plutôt directement le professeur
delfraissy qui aurait pu nous apporter
des réponses
et donc si monsieur vendre ne peux pas
répondre nous les lui transmettront en
lui demandant de bien vouloir nous
éclairer par mail ou par tout moyen pour
compléter notre information
je donne maintenant la parole à madame
benbassa oui je vois là écoutez je
voudrais poser la question d'une
question à monsieur lang
quel serait d'après vous l'efficacité de
cette application dans notre pays où
nous manquons de masques de test et de
médicaments deuxièmement je vais
réitérer une question de marque que j'ai
fait à la présidente du kiel d'abord si
les personnes n'ont pas sinon citoyens
n'ont pas confiance dans le système en
général et ne craignez vous pas que les
potentiels malades souhaite inciter à
cacher leurs symptômes aux services de
santé
parker de conséquences négatives
deuxièmement si cette application
fonctionne se met en marche
est ce qu'on ne devrait pas également
mettre en place une pédagogie pour que
les personnes qui utilise volontairement
cette application ne pense pas que cette
application est suffisante et que
qu'elles n'ont plus besoin
un espace de d'appliquer les gestes
barrière qui sont très importantes où le
port du masque etc
merci merci beaucoup scheer collègues de
vos questions de votre concision
monsieur kerrouche oui merci monsieur le
président je pense en effet monsieur
présent que comme alain richard il fera
peut être auditionné le professeur
delfraissy sur un périmètre plus large
que celui qui est uniquement celui sur
lequel on se perd en jeu ce matin
oui chers que les paramètres de vous
interrompre un instant et la commission
des lois n'étant pas en charge des
questions de sécurité sanitaire
proprement dite il était indispensable
par respect pour le travail de suivi que
fait la commission des affaires sociales
sont ces aspects que nous entendions
monsieur delfraissy sur des questions
qui sont directement de notre compétence
ça ne veut pas dire que les autres
questions soient moins importantes au
contraire souvent elles le sont
davantage encore mais je vous laisse la
parole je n'entends pas un président
mais les questions sanitaires viennent
parfois heurter les questions politiques
c'est vrai notamment dans le cadre des
élections ceci étant ma question n'est
pas celle là pour monsieur wang dans la
vie musulman de vous avez vous avez
expliqué les nouvelles doctrines qui
devait être élaborée et vous proposer un
nouveau déploiement opérationnel d'état
mention de fuite en emportant cela
permettra justement de test et
éventuellement qualité des stratégies
innovantes et le rendu des résultats qui
est le contact racing alors sur cette
fameuse application de traçage mes
questions sont relativement sage d'abord
est ce que une telle activité
une telle application est vraiment
réaliste à combien estimez vous le
déploiement nécessaire de toute
application pour qu'elle ait réellement
un effet dans la population par rapport
à la pandémie
combien de pourcentage de déploiement
sont ils nécessaires sachant que toute
la population ne dispose pas d'un spa
d'un smartphone d'une part et que par
ailleurs il y a une fracture numérique
dans l'utilisation d'autres femmes et
enfin j'ai pu mettre en lumière avec
d'autres collègues chercheurs que
justement du fait même de l'existence de
cette application de tracking il y aura
des stratégies d'évitement qui vont se
mettre en place
comment comptez-vous y répondre et enfin
à une question très technique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous assurer que
puisqu'on utilise la technologie
bluetooth du portable
à aucun moment li li émis par norange de
ça veut dire l'identifiant unique du
téléphone mais communiqué d'une
quelconque façon que ce soit je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues de cet
ensemble de questions monsieur alain
marc enfin président est-ce que vous
m'entendez oui chers collègues nous vous
entendons mais nous ne voyons pas par
une caméra
d'accord je veux savoir chercher
président et la question et à
destination de monsieur wang
si on dispose d'ores et déjà de
statistiques ou du moins d'une
évaluation concernant la comptabilité de
l'évaluation en ligne que certaines
personnes ne soient pour savoir s'ils
sont si leurs symptômes correspondent à
celle du coin 8 et de lorient
derrière et qui est donnée à ce test
numérique allait choisir ensuite pour ce
qui concerne l'application volontaire du
suivi des gens contaminés et des gens
qui ont été en contact avec ces derniers
et qui sont eux-mêmes à l'application
quelle est la temporalité prévu de
l'annnonce de sucre contact s en direct
ou y at il un délai pour que cette
annonce ne soit réalisé merci beaucoup
cher collègue monsieur wang je vous
rends la parole pour répondre à toutes
ces questions
du moins celles d'entre elles qui sont
de votre ressort
merci monsieur le président oui donc à
titre liminaire je vais m'excuser auprès
de ceux qui ont posé des questions
comment en tant que citoyens considèrent
comme comme très légitime et sur
lesquels je ne le veux pas répondre
parce que je sortirai de mon couloir
d'énumérer qui essaient n'aiderait
vraiment personne donc je vous renvoie
votre à d'autres échanges extérieurs
avec les personnes compétentes sur ces
sujets en revanche que je peux vous dire
sur l'application
aujourd'hui le scénario sur lequel on
travaille avec cette application il le
fonctionne que dans un certain nombre de
deux avec un certain nombre de pré
requis l'accès aux tests
une situation de confinement allégé où
il ya un respect des gestes barrières et
notamment le premier d'entre eux plus
essentiel si j'ai bien compris entre
citoyens de rester à deux mètres les uns
des autres
voilà en dehors de son cercle familial
on comptera dans ces conditions là donc
le sic et si deux personnes étaient
amenés par extraordinaire à ne pas
respecter les gestes barrières et à ne
pas respecter cette distance
ceux ci elles avaient toutes les deux si
elles ont toutes les deux l'application
sa part la travel guard dans la mémoire
et l'on veut passer l'information
nécessaire si l'une des deux des
musiques est positive mais quand une
fois donc ça me
cette application telle que là
aujourd'hui on la voit là on a des
cinémas des peuples
elle scelle lot n a de sens que dans le
cadre du respect absolu des
gestes-barrières et à distance sur sur
les garanties vous causer un cependant
des questions sur les garanties en
termes de respect de la vie privée est
ce que l'ime li va être communiqué est
ce que est ce que le coup tout cela va
être utilisé dans l'est dans certains
lieux etc
alors je vais vous faire une réponse la
seule manière pour moi de vérifier ces
garanties puis c'est de vérifier
certainement pas annie sur la bonne
parole ou la bonne parole de n'importe
qui dans le projet là pour moi là ce qui
permet d'assurer la garantie c'est la
transparence sur le code source et sur
les spécifications de cette application
est donc la recommandation que j'ai pu
faire et qui a été reprise par le parle
parle parle par le gouvernement c'est
que cette application soit open source
et que le code source soit publiée et à
disposition de tout le monde et de tous
ceux qui ont comme ça exercer un rôle
très important dans une démocratie comme
la nôtre de vérifier que ça fait je
pense que une application d'une telle
sensibilité et de avec un caractère
aussi inédit en aucun cas ne pourra être
une application sans ouverture du code
sans accès transparent aux codes par des
tiers de confiance est verrouillé par d
une solution comment dire par la
propriété intellectuelle propriétaire
pour ça que dès le départ le pari qui a
été fait c'était de faire ça dans le
cadre d'un projet de recherche ouverte
recherche couverte et à cliquer là
sciences du numérique qui répond à la
science de l'épidémiologie dans des
conditions d'ouverture et de
transparence qui sont les valeurs et le
fonctionnement propre
la science aujourd'hui dans nos
démocraties
voilà ensuite sur les questions de
souveraineté et ça fait une transition
intéressante je pense nous avons été
informés par google et apple vendredi
soir de la solution qu'il de compte est
proposé je n'ai pas de jugement de
valeur à faire sur l'intention de ces
deux acteurs pour contribuer à la
résolution d'une crise telle que nous la
vivons et si j'ai bien compris s'ils
comptent proposer mais pas tout de suite
on parle de hummer en termes de
disponibilité et puis après il faut
faire des développements c'est une
solution clé en main entièrement
packagées où les états qui les autorités
sanitaires qui en auraient besoin
n'auraient plus qu'à récupérer leur
leurs outils à mettre leur logo je
caricature un peu mais à peine à mettre
quelques quelques quelques écrans pour
faciliter la navigation par sont
inutilisés et puis et puis c'est bon et
puis ça marche donc ça veut dire que sur
un point technique google et apple
définissent eux-mêmes le modèle
sanitaire qu'est ce qui fait que de
contacts qualifiés définissent eux-mêmes
garde azadi les identifiants tout
protocole c'est le leur je ne sais même
pas s'ils n'ont pas vu de mettre le code
en open source
samoa du personnel je pense que ça pose
d'énormes enjeux de souveraineté
d'énormes enjeux de vanter les mérites
ça fait écho à des crocs occupation j'ai
pu j'ai pu travailler dans les fonctions
précédentes au sein de l'état qui est en
fait la capacité des pouvoirs publics à
savoir avoir une forme de régulation sur
ses acteurs il ya ne pas être dépendant
donc donc après on fera ce qu'on pourra
et si on ne peut pas faire autrement
parce qu'on a quand même besoin de
google et apple
donc pour l'instant on est vraiment dans
une logique de collaboration de
participation et de négociation avec eux
pour pouvoir avoir accès à un certain
nombre de fonctionnalités sur ces
terminaux qui nous permette qui
permettent à l'état de manière
souveraine autorités sanitaires
publiques nationales dans une
coordination européenne
de pouvoir décider en toute souveraineté
de ce qui est le souhaite proposer à
leurs concitoyens
si on a encore des négociations si ces
négociations n'aboutissaient pas et que
nous n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
reprendre la solution clé en main de
google apple voilà je pense qu'il y aura
des arbitrages et des priorités à
établir dès que cela devra nous tous
nous interroger collectivement et en
premier lieu la représentation nationale
sur ce que l'acier cela signifie en
termes de d'indépendance et de
souveraineté sur ces questions
numériques qui dépasse vraiment très
largement la simple possibilité d'outils
numériques qui nous facilitera et donc
souveraineté ça veut dire pour répondre
à vos questions sur le sénateur très
précises sur les différentes briques
open source
hébergement s'il le faut sur des
serveurs et a piloté par l'état en train
sous contrôle et sous vos dates aux
audits habilités de l'état est-ce qu'il
serait impossible avec nutrition google
apple puisque c'est c'est a priori sur
leurs serveurs excusez moi quand il ya
beaucoup de questions je reprends mes
notes
oui il m'a même pas ça mais ça frise le
hamas assure sur la pédagogie vous avez
raison il va falloir beaucoup de
pédagogie sur cette application vraiment
beaucoup
je ne suis pas sûr que la communication
gouvernementale il suffira je pense que
si chacun d'eux mêmes quand on vient du
numérique
cette application la manière dont elle
fonctionne les questions qu'elle soulève
tout ça demande à tout le monde y
compris des gens ils sont experts de
passer un peu de temps dessus donc et
donc ça va être un effort de pédagogie
immense et aussi aussi une question
d'une question de confiance c'est pour
ça que les questions de transparence et
d'ouverture de notabilités de stars sont
très importantes
et puis aussi ne pas oublier pour ce à
quoi doit servir et servait uniquement
sur un plan sanitaire
parce que ce sont les scientifiques et
ceux qui sont en responsabilité en
expertise de ces questions si le
prescrivent
sous le contrôle évidemment des pouvoirs
publics et de la représentation
nationale
voilà alors sur les questions de
l'inclusion j'y reviens moi je pense
très concrets que même si cette
application
imaginez prenons un village en haute
savoie par exemple 200 300 400 habitants
où finalement assez peu de gens l'aurait
installé pour plein de raisons soit
parce que ils sont en incapacité de
l'installer ils n'ont pas de smartphone
où ils comprennent rien ils n'ont pas
confiance et c'est elodie eux c'est leur
choix et que quelques personnes
seulement le réinstaller notamment les
plus peut-être les plus connectés ceux
qui se déplacent tous les jours qui vont
travailler en dehors de en dehors de
leurs de leur village
voilà le simple fait de ce que ces
personnes n'a imaginé par exemple un
seul et c'est très concret je crois en
l'homme en voltige qui ensemble 6 1 un
habitant de ce village a passé sa
journée dans la grande villa côté à
travailler etc
il a respecté les gestes barrière jeu
malencontreusement il a eu un contact
trop prolongé il a suivi un contact
prolongé avec quelqu'un et il revient
dans son village suisse avis et et puis
pareil au sein du village cette barrière
sont pas forcément très bien respectée
et les gens ne peuvent pas s'empêcher de
se saluer et d'un peu trop près et c'est
bon mais j en trois jours après en fait
la personne avec qui ce qu'il a joué
avec un contact devient est testée
positive lui sera lui le sera lui pourra
appeler les autorités sanitaires que son
médecin il est de prévenir et et les
autorités sanitaires dans le respect de
l'anonymat de ce patient de sept
personnes pourront savoir que dans ce
village il ya quelqu'un qui est un cas
contacts et qui est peut-être positif
qui a lui même été menés tout le monde
donc même si les autres n'ont pas de
smartphone ça permettra quand même à
cette force sanitaires à des équipes
très mobile très agile d'intervenir et
de et d'être extrêmement vigilante voire
de venir faire des enquêtes manuel en
disant si vous avez croisé est ce que
vous avez parlé à ce monsieur
certains voient là et là on fait le
travail alors à un moment oui bah oui
tout n'est pas anonyme je pars pas
l'application mais je parle de travail
des enquêteurs sur le terrain
à un moment il faut mater n'en parle non
il se passe rien si personne ne dit rien
on ne peut rien faire mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que mon compte mon
message c'est de dire que oui de mon
point de vue l'application elle peut
avoir un sens notamment en zone rurale
ou dans des zones où on peut faire un
travail à la main à l'abri mais je
reviens sur un problème nous que nous
avons déjà abordé avec vous même et le
professeur delfraissy qui évalue et tout
à l'heure à 10 à 15000 contamination par
jour la mi mai vous imaginez cette
opération que vous venez de décrire
reproduite dix à quinze mille fois en
france on a évoqué aussi tout à l'heure
les effectifs et qui ont été mobilisés
en corée du sud est et ce qu'il faudrait
mobiliser en france pour faire la même
chose qu'en corée du sud on mesure en
vous écoutant que effectivement même
dans le cas de ce village
l'application peut avoir un intérêt mais
il faut qu'elles moyens suivent
complètement de toute façon moi
aujourd'hui les équipes projet le
travail dans un souci potez que les
moyens suivent
il n'y aura pas de miracle avec cette
application il n'y aura pas de miracle
technologique et ne résoudra pas la
crise en elle même si derrière il n'a
pas les mains qui il n'ya pas l'accès
aux tests
il n'y a pas le respect des
gestes-barrières on voit se dessiner un
intérêt individuel plus qu'à l'intérêt
collectif
oui ben ali le s'il n'y a pas les moyens
la théorie oui il subsiste je suis
informé que j'ai été en contact avec une
personne contaminée je prends des
précautions pour moi même et ma famille
je me fais des pistes et voilà ça c'est
un exemple d'utilisation individuelle
mais la protection du village et de la
communauté
c'est une autre affaire après on
pourrait dire la technologie est
disponible pour concevoir des choses qui
vont beaucoup plus loin beaucoup plus
loin
moi je crois que nous n'avons pas envie
d'aller sur ce terrain là la mouette
personnel je n'ai pas envie d'y aller et
est-ce qu'on peut concevoir qui
permettent d'aller beaucoup plus loin
oui beaucoup de poésie d'ailleurs j'ai
reçu beaucoup de projets extrêmement
créatif qui faisait assez peu de cas de
rejet bd et les mêmes de nos pratiques
et nos valeurs ou à la fois sur un plan
sanitaire mais aussi sur un plan de
police administrative pouvait servir du
numérique pour après tout le passeport
d'immunité j'ai localisé au localiser
les gens savoir si l'on installé
l'application savoir si l'on savoir si
l'on activé ou pas le tous énormément de
technologies qui sont à disposition pour
faire des pour réaliser un quadrillage
extrême
je comprends servent comme mais même en
dehors de la crise voilà donc
aujourd'hui la question c'est est-ce que
de quoi est capable la technologie sait
où sont nos lits quelles limites nous
sur un plan démocratique interne de
valeur au sein de l'europe
nous mettons nous tous différents je
vous remercie vous avez d'autres
compléments à nous apporter par rapport
aux questions posées ou vous avez
terminé dans votre réponse est non je
parce que j'ai répondu j'ai répondu à
toutes les questions y avait une
question sur la temporalité qui était la
dernière question quel est votre
question sur l'évaluation en ligne le
questionnaire aux chocs sur la question
de la pertinence de l'évaluation en
ligne je n'ai pas de réponse mais je
sais que les idéologistes à faster dans
les hôpitaux
ça leur serve en respect de évidemment
je donne à mes forces air sûr qu'elle a
collecté des données épidémiologiques et
à comprendre un peu mieux comment
comment ce virus fonctionne pour revenir
sur l'application sur la temporalité
pour l'instant c'est est envisagé c'est
que dès qu'un cas contact avec un cas
diagnostiqué positif est en tout cas
déclenché de là où il est l'aller-retour
son téléphone de manière instantanée
temps réel tous tous les cas contacts
qu'il faut notifier seront notifiés il
parle il n'est pas prévu de délai
puisque justement l'enjeu c'est une
course de vitesse
si je comprends bien l'information est
instantané à partir du moment où la
personne contaminée
la livre sur le
sur l'application mais ça peut venir
trois jours ou six jours quinze jours
après la rencontre
absolument en fait il faut probablement
enfin la ville où il faut prendre en
compte un historique de 14 jours pour
pouvoir voir voir voire plus ça c'est à
moi de le dire je ça c'est dans la
configuration de l'application que ce
qui sera décidé si l'application de
votre jour tout à fait c'est l'histoire
qui correspond à l'activation est donc à
la possibilité d'avoir été d'avoir été
le marité contagieux et donc le groupe
de contaminer et ensuite les données
historiques qui peut être détruits y
apparaît très bien alors il n'y a aucune
raison objective de garde
très bien je vous remercie beaucoup
chers collègues avez-vous d'ultimes
question je n'en vois pas venir et bien
monsieur wang
merci de vos réponses de votre
contribution mais parce que la
représentation nationale soit éclairé
sur le sujet mais ce n'est pas terminé
la séance est levée
merci à vous
le conseil scientifique a donc été
auditionné par la commission des lois du
sénat notamment sur les mesures de
traçage numérique censée enrayer cette
épidémie de coronavirus noter que le
président de la république emmanuel
macron souhaite un débat au parlement
sur cette question avant le lundi 11 mai
date de la fin du confinement au sens
strict voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission si vous souhaitez continuer à
vous informer sur cette crise sanitaire
vous pouvez aller sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat
[Musique]
et